en este vídeo vamos a ver algunos
problemas que involucran a la
aceleración constante pero no vamos a
resolver los problemas vamos a analizar
lo que sabemos y cuál es la incógnita
para así poder identificar cuál fórmula
usar antes de ver los ejemplos yo les
quiero decir que es muy importante
comprender de dónde vienen estas
ecuaciones desarrollar una buena
comprensión de la posición la velocidad
la aceleración la distancia y cómo se
relacionan entre sí en cada ccaa de mí
tenemos muchos vídeos en donde
explicamos estos temas que les pueden
ayudar a comprender estos conceptos una
vez que ya tenemos bien está comprensión
pues estas fórmulas van a ser algo así
como usar una calculadora para ayudarnos
a resolver más rápidamente un problema
nos ayudan a ahorrar tiempo de la misma
forma que si ustedes ya saben sumar
restar multiplicar y dividir al momento
de usar una calculadora saben qué es lo
que está haciendo la calculadora y una
vez que comprenden esto pues la
calculadora es una herramienta muy
valiosa y es algo similar lo que ocurre
con estas fórmulas son
herramientas que nos van a ayudar mucho
una vez que comprendemos de dónde vienen
así que ya ha explicado esto vamos a ver
cada uno de estos ejemplos nos dicen que
un tren acelera a una taza de 1.35
metros por segundo al cuadrado cuánto
tiempo le toma a alcanzar su máxima
rapidez 80 kilómetros por hora se inicia
en reposo analicemos esto y veamos qué
es lo que nos dice nos dice que un tren
acelera a una taza de 1.35 metros por
segundo al cuadrado esto es bastante
directo nos dice cuál es la aceleración
lo escribimos la aceleración es de 1.35
metros por segundo al cuadrado
luego nos dice cuánto tiempo le toma
alcanzar su máxima rapidez 80 kilómetros
por hora se inicia en reposo esto está
un poquito más complicado pero si
comenzamos al principio nos dice cuánto
tiempo le toma a alcanzar su máxima
rapidez así que aquí nos están
preguntando por el tiempo el tiempo es
nuestra incógnita
continuemos nos dice cuánto tiempo le
toma alcanzar su máxima rapidez 80
kilómetros por hora si inicia en reposo
pues aquí tenemos su máxima rapidez la
velocidad que alcanza cuando deja de
acelerar es de 80 kilómetros por hora
esta es nuestra velocidad final 80
kilómetros por hora
a veces verán esto escrito como b
subíndice f para indicar explícitamente
que es la velocidad final así que la
anotación no puede variar en algunas
clases de física pero no importa cual
notación usen siempre tienen que
preguntarse a qué se refiere cada
símbolo ok veamos qué más nos dice nos
dice que inicia en reposo esto de que
inicia en reposo quiere decir que al
principio su velocidad inicial es de
cero así que la velocidad inicial es de
cero metros por segundo muy bien ya
analizamos este problema y vemos que en
ningún lugar se menciona el cambio en la
distancia sólo están involucrados estos
cuatro valores así que veamos cuál de
estas ecuaciones involucra a estos
cuatro palos
espero que no involucre el cambio en la
distancia ya que no conocemos delta
equis y no nos están preguntando por
delta x estas dos tienen a delta x así
que no las contamos esta de aquí abajo
también tiene a delta x así que no nos
va a servir por lo tanto la fórmula que
nos sirve es esta de aquí arriba aquí
tenemos la velocidad final la velocidad
inicial la aceleración y el tiempo todas
las variables que estamos ocupando así
que ya encontramos que para este
problema podemos usar esta fórmula para
continuar resolviendo esto tendríamos
que poner los valores y despejar al
tiempo para finalmente encontrar cuál es
el valor del tiempo pero en este vídeo
no vamos a resolver estos problemas solo
vamos a encontrar cuál es la fórmula
necesaria para resolverlos veamos la
siguiente pregunta para incorporarse a
una autopista un auto acelera desde el
reposo a una tasa de 2.40 metros por
segundo al cuadrado durante 12 segundos
qué tan lejos viaja el auto durante esos
doce segundos cuál es la velocidad final
del auto este problema tiene dos
preguntas vamos a enfocarnos primero en
la primera pregunta veamos qué es lo que
sabemos para incorporarse a una
autopista un auto acelera desde el
reposo a una taza de 2.40 metros por
segundo al cuadrado durante 12 segundos
aquí tenemos bastante información vamos
a analizarla nos dice que acelera desde
el reposo lo que nos dice que la
velocidad inicial es de 0 desde el
reposo quiere decir que no se estaba
moviendo inicialmente lo escribimos esto
igual que en el ejemplo anterior nos
dice que la velocidad inicial es de 0
metros por segundo esto no siempre es el
caso pero coincidió que en estos
problemas así fuera así que el auto
acelera desde el reposo a una tasa de
2.40 metros por segundo al cuadrado esto
nos dice cuál es la aceleración la
aceleración es de 2.40 metros por
segundo al cuadrado
y en todos estos problemas es importante
darnos cuenta si todos los objetos se
mueven en la misma dirección si se
mueven en la dirección positiva o en la
dirección negativa o se aceleran en la
dirección positiva o aceleran en la
dirección negativa y parece que en estos
ejemplos que tenemos aquí todos los
objetos se mueven en la misma dirección
todo se mueve en la dirección positiva y
también acelera en la misma dirección
aquí no tendremos signos negativos con
que trabajar pero es importante darnos
cuenta si el problema nos indica algún
cambio de dirección solo en caso de
encontrar algo que tenga una dirección o
aceleración negativa y esto pueda
afectar nuestro resultado así que todo
está acelerando en la misma dirección
por lo que podemos decir que la
aceleración es hacia adelante así que
este auto está acelerando a 2.40 metros
por segundo al cuadrado y también nos
dice que esto lo está haciendo durante
12 segundos así que escribimos esto
también 12 segundos
muy bien conocemos tres cosas aquí y se
darán cuenta de que cuando conocemos al
menos tres cosas en problemas como estos
tres es el número mágico ya que si
tenemos tres de estos podremos encontrar
lo que nos preguntan usando estas
ecuaciones la primera pregunta nos dice
qué tan lejos viaja el auto durante esos
doce segundos bueno esto de qué tan
lejos viaja se refiere a esta delta x
que es el cambio en la posición así que
en esta primera pregunta no esta
interrogante es delta x ahora vean que
no tenemos este dato por lo que tenemos
que buscar una ecuación que no tenga
este dato de la velocidad final así que
vamos a buscar una ecuación que tenga
estos otros cuatro valores esta no nos
sirve porque tiene la velocidad final
ésta tampoco nos sirve porque tiene
también la velocidad final esta de aquí
no tiene la velocidad final así que nos
puede servir tiene el cambio en posición
que es delta x que es lo que estamos
buscando justo aquí la velocidad inicial
aquí está también tenemos el tiempo
tenemos la aceleración y aquí de nuevo
el tiempo así que tiene todo lo que
necesitamos y no incluye las cosas que
desconocemos así que para la primera
pregunta de este problema vamos a usar
esta fórmula y la segunda pregunta nos
dice cuál es la velocidad final del auto
lo que quiere decir que ahora nuestra
incógnita es esta bueno ya identificamos
las cosas que conocemos y si ya
resolvimos la primera pregunta de este
problema entonces ya tendremos el valor
del está equis pero suponiendo que aún
no hemos encontrado este valor qué
fórmula nos sirve pues vamos a buscar
una fórmula que tenga la velocidad final
en ella y que no tenga a delta x en ella
y que por supuesto tenga estas otras
tres cosas que sí conozco si revisamos
las fórmulas nos damos cuenta que de
nuevo vamos a tener a esta primera
fórmula como solución para esta pregunta
ya que es la ecuación que no tiene al
cambio en la posición en ella así que
subrayamos esto con verde para indicar
que es la fórmula a usar para resolver
nuestra
segunda pregunta y en el caso de que ya
tuviéramos este valor pues podríamos
usar cualquiera de estas fórmulas para
resolver esta pregunta siempre y cuando
tenga nuestra velocidad final en ella
espero que al analizar estos dos
ejemplos les ayude a encontrar la
fórmula correcta para los problemas que
les toque resolver y sepan encontrar qué
es la información que les dan
cuál es la incógnita que les piden y con
esto encontrar cuál fórmula les va a ser
útil para resolver el problema